[Music]
it's unfortunate with anybody not just a
journalist determines the storyline
before they actually consider all the
facts the only time that it's good to
have an ending and work backwards is if
you're writing a screenplay or a book or
maybe a poem or something similar to
that in general it's much better if
you're in a journalistic environment to
be able to make sure that you actually
are considering all the facts and very
often some of the best stories and the
best reporting comes where the actual
facts don't jive with what the original
hypothesis was because it actually can
be more revelatory it can be more
insightful it can be deeper and it can
be more impactful if you're not going in
the conventional wisdom that's
especially bad in our environment when
you have reporters who are writing about
similar topics and try to find some new
way to be able to discuss the same thing
that we hear over and over and over
again
one of my pet peeves is the fact that
you have this tendency and I won't point
fingers at that specifically who but in
general it's too frequent that outlets
and individuals are pressured to focus
on the quantity of the stories that
they're writing as opposed to Nets out
of the quality because it really hurts
themselves and it hurts the perception
when you're looking at reporting on
really serious issues whether it be in
government or local issues or energy or
education or any of the things that
really are very foreign policy that
matter in our world it's really
unfortunate if you have someone who
feels the need for clickbait or for
other reasons to do ten stories on
something when two or three of them were
actually really strong excellent
reporting but the public sort of tired
of them because they weren't the first
the second or the third and maybe there
was a 68 and the 10th by the time they
get to those they're tired of the
subject they're less likely to read it
and there it won't have as much of an
impact there's a fatigue about subjects
and I think that there's less of an
understanding the media about how
damaging that potentially can be when
they're dealing with serious subjects
because they talk about them too many
times the minutiae of the every single
tree being discussed instead of the
actual impact
Forrest he actually be very damaging
look Oh worlds moves very quickly
instant gratification is there anybody
that has children sees the way that
they're used to a world where they can
have information or gratification in the
form of games or purchasing things
online or whatever it might be at the
touch of a button it's much faster and
so people have those expectations if you
think about how long dial-up used to be
when you would go online and the
patience you would have to have and if
someone told you you were going to wait
10 or 20 seconds now before everything
was going to work then that was
fantastic because you would cut it down
from maybe a minute or longer and now
people expect it to be instantaneous you
see ads that are focused on the fastest
speed and the difference between a lot
of them are ones that sheep regular
human beings cannot notice at all
however being fastest and best and first
is something that's critical and that I
respect that I understand the
competitive nature of things I
understand why reporters who put a lot
of time into it who may get who may get
shafted by somebody then trying to jump
ahead in that line but just throwing up
something right before but I still
believe that there is a place for the
longer more in-depth insightful pieces
and then you can have the short-form
analysis and you can have the response
and you could have the explanation and
you can have the feedback on that but I
still believe that it's important to
give time in the truth is they're made
or in short form that can also be very
substantive I believe it can come in all
forms a soundbite may be very effective
because it may be very insightful into
someone's feelings about something it
could be it could tell a real story in
itself so I don't think it's one or the
other I just think there needs to be
more of a responsibility about both
[Music]